klimaschutz heißt die existenzfrage
unserer zeit deswegen genau deswegen hat
angela merkel auch die besten der besten
versammelt in ihrem sogenannten klima
kabinett ja es sind nicht die gleichen
minister wie immer nur halt im klima
kabinett wo diese gottverdammten
superhelden dann ein teures klimapaket
ausbaldowert haben das nach einhelliger
expertenmeinung leider vorne und hinten
nicht reicht klar erstmal mussten die
verfahrensfragen geklärt werden im
frühjahr hier die umweltministerin
erklärt ein erster überblick ist es
erstmal in der nächsten sitzung gemein
wo wir einmal uns einen überblick über
alle bereiche auch verschaffen aber wir
wollen auch nach diesem ersten überblick
nochmal genauer entscheiden wann wir was
diskutieren also genau gesagt wer wann
genau wie genau was genau wir wollen da
uns einen ersten überblick verschaffen
ich brauche mehr details ja ich hätte da
details ich hätte details der ausbau der
windenergie ist nicht zuletzt durch
groko gesetze praktisch zum erliegen
gekommen herzlichen glückwunsch und beim
braunkohle ausstieg können sie sich
aktuell mit den betreibern auf keine
entschädigung einigen weil die
offensichtlich zu gierig sind muss uns
der start am ende vielleicht doch sachen
ja ich sag jetzt mal das hässliche wort
regelrecht verbieten gefährliche idee
denn vielen bürgern rechts jetzt schon
ja da wird doch der soja bartling in der
pfanne verrückt deutschland ist auf dem
besten weg in die ökodiktatur mit
albrecht humboldt liebe zuschauer 2009
10 das jahr in dem die berliner öko
stalinisten endgültig durchdrehen
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch herr
welche ich persönlich hab nichts gegen
die umwelt ich war auch schon mal da ist
eine schöne gegend aber was hier im
namen der heiligen greta geschieht das
gibt wirklich auf keine fair gehandelte
kuhhaut diese mutige frau bringt es auf
den punkt
eine grüne idioten diktatur
entschuldigung abgesehen davon dass die
grünen im bund seit 14 jahren gar nicht
mehr regieren wir wollen nicht ernsthaft
die grünen mit hitler und stalin
vergleichen ja gut da haben sie
natürlich recht der vergleich hinkt
hitler und stalin haben mich nie
gezwungen den müll zu trennen
ja gut die drehen durch diese
gutmenschen nehmen wir doch nur mal was
demnächst bei uns alles verboten ist ich
hab das auch spaß alles einmal
mitgebracht
[Musik]
hier plastiktüten verboten
stroheim verboten also wie gesagt
plastiktüten und strohhalme sonst
eigentlich nichts es wird alles verboten
was spaß macht was hatte ich immer nur
für ein spaß mit strohhalmen bald muss
sich direkt aus dem glas saufen wie so
ein tier und dann wundern sich alle
wenden gegen dfb will also was stimmt
der humboldt was stimmt wir haben 2009
10 alle sehr viel über klima geredet
auch in dieser sendung aber gleichzeitig
haben wir drei neue deutsche rekorde
aufgestellt
erstmals wurden über eine million neue
suvs und geländewagen zugelassen rekord
im ersten halbjahr so viele flugreisen
die noch nie und mehr verpackungsmüll
als jemals zuvor
mit anderen worten wenn das hier nur öko
diktatur ist dann funktioniert die aber
verdammt schlecht freundchen deswegen
verleiht die heute-show uns allen heute
den eingebildeten diktatur vollpfosten
der gar nicht da ist
halten sie mal entschuldigung haben sie
doch auf der welt gehören leid tut mir
leid so sei und dieser posten geht
übrigens auch an alle die glauben in
einer meinungsdiktatur zu leben nur weil
man sie für bestimmte ansichten
gelegentlich kritisiert gerade die
rechten bei uns sind hier viel
empfindlicher als man denkt ja weil wir
hier inzwischen eine ganz schlimme
gesprächskultur haben selbst
untereinander lassen sich die rechten ja
heutzutage gar nicht mehr ausreden die
neulich bei der pid an
[Musik]
ich habe viele ideen gelten fordert
lässt du mich jetzt mal wüsste man
irgendwann stellt eure politische
einstellungen können die mainzer so
schön einen nagel in die wand geschlagen
hat das musste fragen du bist mit
gegenfragen müsste an gruppen laden
schließt noch mehr menschen überleben
das depotvermögen letztlich erst mal
jeden text und nicht jetzt mal bist du
immer du mich jetzt mal ist jetzt mag
ich viele grün
[Applaus]
das
das ist doch das ist doch traurig man
will einfach nur seine meinung sagen
vorsicht die regenbogenpresse lässt du
dich jetzt mal ich wollte doch nur lässt
du mich jetzt mal ein reichtum volt
lässt du mich jetzt mal
ja der mutter rosa braten in der pfanne
haut goldstrand es noch den besten geht
in diesen produkten mit albrecht
humboldt
[Musik]
wir haben ein paket erhalten dass das
klima retten soll
da ist es viel zu winzig und nicht mal
zur hälfte voll
bald gibt es zum weihnachtsfest
nie wieder geschenke stress denn dann
schauen wir alle beim welt und
egal
zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den plan
märz
diese
doch viel
ich kriege
[Musik]
durch das meer zu
und 8
ist nicht gut
nichts
[Musik]
ganz
[Applaus]
spox
fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]